tom yes you auditioned for ken
i did many times um but i'm talking
about thor
changed your life it did yeah my life
has changed thanks to this man
yes and um it's a pleasure to be sitting
with him on your sofa
is that where the hiddlestoners came
from from loki i i i i that's a
whole other world i don't know about you
know all about the hiddlestoners
they're very sweet mostly benign um
and um yeah there's there's a few of
them um
and then the hiddlestoners get hiddle
boners
this all comes from him not me
i don't know i i've nev that's something
i've not i've been put out
i haven't put that out into
your pardon the expression i haven't
extended that into the
no it's it's uh the
yeah you are fabulous as loki absolutely
brilliant
but apparently you originally originally
auditioned no offense is meant by my
incredulity here that's right
but you originally auditioned for thor
yep did you encourage him to do that ken
uh it was a it was a very uh sort of um
brilliant kind of uh pitch for the part
i mean he'd come in and wowed the room
um
an emerging and evolving script so it
was always changing but the fair play to
tom he just
went for it in the end ken why why did
you go with this then
um genetically modified material
he wouldn't mind my saying that um he's
a sort of genetic anomaly i think
i was very i was a bit embarrassed when
when we came to do the scene in the
movie where he takes his shirt off i
just felt
a little uncomfortable talking about the
sort of how we would do it
and i felt as though well maybe he'll
feel that he shouldn't or couldn't or
it's a bit whatever
i said i remember going to see him that
morning saying look you know
it would be i think it might be good if
you get your shirt up but
you may be feeling he said of course i'm
going to get my bloody shirt off man
i've been
i've been training for nine months for
this [__] thing
all right you know people love the event
and now
tom middleton you have found offered
such specific
fan art that's a lot yeah and does it
all come from this one
scene was it the first thor movie with
the spear
right right yeah yes um
there's a scene in a first thor film
where my i'm
trying to attack thor chris hemsworth as
thor with a spear
and i jump in the air and he dodges out
the way
and i bring the spear down and it wedges
itself into the floor
and then i use the use it to
spin myself around and kick him in the
chest
which has been interpreted by fans as
um a demonstration of my hidden talent
at pole dancer
there's so much of this this is just one
example of loki
really going for it on the pole
is that japanese and that's what you
wear in the movie
yeah have you not seen it yeah that's
loki's outfit
yeah i've never i've not seen that one
oh really
we'll print it out you can take it home
but you actually went to locations yeah
i do think actually it's the great uh
jordan
roberts who directed it really was
insistent that we go to
places on earth which are both beautiful
and dangerous um so that it didn't feel
like a digital
environment it felt like a real place so
we went to um
oahu in hawaii
[Laughter]
[Music]
we went to uh queensland in australia
that's scarier i'll give you that yeah
there are rainforests there and they
have the most um all the most dangerous
animals in the world are
in the state of queensland in australia
yeah crazy yeah um snakes spiders
some of queens are going yeah i escaped
um
you know you'd see the final web spiders
starting to bring but people do
impressions of people
do impressions of you don't they very
rarely yeah
very rare yeah am i in your cannon
no no i mean i haven't it's like i
always i feel like and i wouldn't be
able to do it until i met you but i have
do you want me to go for that you get it
i don't know so i can't have the cards i
need the cards
no don't worry you never know all the
cards
so welcome back so
for you you've never been on the show
because you know because it's not just
singing it's very specific thing the
yodeling and everything i mean
presumably not everyone can do that
so if you discovered you couldn't do it
were they going to fire you or were they
going to
were they going to dub hank williams how
what was going to happen i honestly
don't know
can you yoda's robert de niro
[Laughter]
uh let me check no
can you give us a little bit so it goes
a little something like this
um oh god here we go
[Music]
blue
i wanted to i wanted to say uh
congratulations to you
why didn't you win a huge award last
couple of weeks
it was almost like you're going to die
soon awards it was it was one of them it
was a
national
during my year tell him to shut up
tom edelson university have you have you
had any bad reviews no
conversation would make a man feel good
graeme
no i was in a play i'd never ever been
professionally reviewed
and in the paper the next day was a
british theater critic who said i was
completely out of place
too young too radha
and projecting about as much masculinity
as graham norton
[Applause]
[Music]
dragged into your bad reviews
[Laughter]
you acted in in school but you were in
school i mean how posh is this
you've got to see a school production
and tom hiddleston's in it with eddie
redmayne
right well um yes uh
he was a great talent even then he was
at the start he was a huge star
and we were in um a school production of
a passage to india
by ian foster
there must be some really depressed
parents going to see that
a passage to they're doing a passage to
india
how long was it i have no idea very
long yeah so um uh all boys school
they're only halfway
[Music]
the great eddie redmayne the now uh
oscar winning yeah redmayne was
playing the female lead and uh in in the
passage of india there's a there's a
expedition to this cultural landmark
called the marabar caves by elephant
i'm delighted to reveal that i played
the front
right leg of the elephant that eddie was
running
um and four of you to make the elephant
that's right yeah yeah and he was
sitting on you
he's he's sitting we're holding a table
um with a cushion on top of it
and also a tablecloth to cover our faces
because
our bodies are the elephant um yes so
that's um that sounds
awful
i imagine just sitting there thinking i
haven't had a drink or at school
but carrying a some boy dresses a girl
on top of a table
and my son's playing the front legs
you know i think a lot of young actors
they you know they revere you so they
they look to you
the other thing you inspire is
impressions people doing impressions now
when people do impressions of you is it
like
sort of nails on a chalkboard or do you
kind of enjoy it
no i kind of enjoy it especially if they
do it well
uh so no i i it's great
i love it i only ask
no because because any hiddlestoners
watching will know
uh tom hiddleston does impressions you
do represent a lot of people so who's in
your canon
it's a it's a expression of admiration
just to be clear
um so i do i do uh impressions of people
that i i
admire and i sort of listen to them i
get the first time i did an impression
that
anyone was aware of i was just telling a
story about midnight in paris the woody
allen film i was in
and how i never read the whole script
and i and i thought it was set in the
20s
and um i turned up and i bumped into
owen wilson who didn't look like he was
in the 20s at all
and uh and i said to him i said so wait
hold on who are you playing cause i'm
playing f scott fitzgerald and i know
cory stole's playing ernest hemingway
and we're all playing figures of history
and he went
oh no no no no no i i i'm from now i go
back into new york
there's a time machine it's kind of it's
kind of cool and it's kind of woody and
you just kind of it's kind of awesome
very good
but uh i mean
i've been made to do impressions of my
fellow avengers um
uh i think everyone has an impression of
christopher walken because he's just
he's such an easy
kind of you know i feel
like what this show needs is more
cowbell
depends on what you'd like me to say
basically there's no
punctuation anything that
comes out of my mouth
i know whole pages of heat you surprised
me
so i there's this there's the scene in
the middle of the film which you'll be
familiar with you were there
the one person you don't need to explain
it to
don't
they're separated like a great thriller
they're separated
from for the entire film and they meet
twice once at the end of once in the
middle
and it takes place at a restaurant la
it's a great scene it's one of the great
pieces of screen acting you can hope to
watch there it is
there's a picture of it it's like a it's
a mutual recognition
of each other anyway so there's a bit
where they have like they sit and have
coffee and have tea and talk about stuff
i'm going on i apologize
anyway so al pacino at one point al
pacino says this he goes uh
so
[Laughter]
we're sitting here like a couple of
regular fellas i mean
you do what you do i do what i gotta do
if i'm there and i gotta put you away
i don't like it but if it's between you
and some poor bastard whose wife are
gonna turn into a widow
brother you are going down
[Music]
and then all right and then and so then
and then it cut and then michael man
cuts back to
the esteemed gentleman at the end of the
sofa
what if you do got me in
i'm not gonna put you down
moving face to face yeah
but i will not hesitate not for a second
that's my
this is so this is so meta
i feel like i've gone into a parallel
universe where um
you're playing all these parts i
apologize that's great
you're the president of ken brown that
was my favorite scene was it your
favorite scene yeah
is it still yeah
no no but my favorite scene that was
written before not because of
doing it but i just my favorite scene
written in the film
you know that it's a great piece of
writing yeah it feels like it plays in
two
in two singles in a way like yeah yeah
and it's it's like
the most beautiful game of tennis did
you each do lots of takes what did you
do lots of times we get how many takes
we did i don't think we did more than
five to eight or nine at the moment
maybe maybe last second
you talk about your dreams and you talk
about your life
it's so great it's so great there's a
bit another bit where you go
we know you say he says uh he says uh
pacino says
so you never wanted a regular-type life
and and uh bob may i call you bob yeah
bob says what's that barbecues and ball
games
[Applause]
[Music]